do you find it hard to come up with
video ideas are you racking your brain
just to figure out what type of video
should I make that will actually get
views well in this live broadcast we are
sharing the one powerful way that you
can find video ideas that will actually
get views and if we're just meeting my
name is Heather Torres and I'm part of
the think team here part of think media
and think marketing and you're watching
our live Q&A we do this one time every
couple of weeks where we share a little
bit of strategy with you and then we get
into your Q&A and I'm fired up for
today's session and I also have with us
the marketing director of think media
Melissa Caputo Mel how you doing today I
am great Heather thanks I'm so excited
to talk about this topic today I just
got a little preview of it and you guys
are going to love it yeah I think this
is a really fun topic to Melissa because
as creators ourselves this can be
something where you're like what video
should I make next I don't even know you
have all these ideas but you can't
really decide which ones you should make
or how you should word that title right
yep definitely it's a it's a constant
struggle because we are always going
through this process of creating new
videos and it's that struggle of always
having to come up with fresh ideas so I
think no matter where you are in your
YouTube journey this is going to be
really helpful tip yes all right well
let's go ahead and get into this one tip
here this power session the one power
the one powerful way to find video ideas
that actually get views and before we
get started real quick just want you to
let you know that this video is brought
to you by our free one-hour youtube
master class at two master class comm
this is where if you're ready to grow
your YouTube channel this year and you
want to deep dive into a part of the
training that we teach from our
Signature Academy video ranking Academy
you can do this one our free youtube
class by going to think master class
calm that is the place where you can go
if you've not taken the master class
make sure to take it because it will be
coming down soon this is a one-hour free
class all
how to dominate on YouTube this year and
get your strategy right well let me know
in the comments real quick do you ever
feel overwhelmed when you're trying to
come up with video ideas I know like I
said as a creator myself this is
something that I I was even struggling
with today trying to come up with this
video idea and sometimes it can be hard
because here we are writing all these
things down and we're so close to it
right you're so close to your topic that
sometimes you don't know well what video
should I make and how should I title
that video and I want to share a really
cool resource with you it's called
answer at the public calm I want to
bring this up for you answer the public
comm and here's what's so cool about
answer the public comm you can on their
free trial they have a free and
additional paid trials you can type into
here right on that line let's say
homeschooling I'm a homeschooling mom
and I make videos about homeschooling
and let's see what comes up when you
type in answer the public comm well if
you scroll down here here are 80
questions that people are actually
asking these are actual video ideas that
I could make things like homeschooling
how homeschooling works I could make the
video I'm trying to read it sideways how
homeschooling works in South Africa
maybe if I am talking to someone
interviewing someone from South Africa
is homeschooling good I mean there's so
many questions this is just 80 questions
right here and you can now take these
actual questions and do a Q&A do a one
question one answer style video this is
a great way to get content out sometimes
you want to make these big grand videos
but really it could literally be about
one question one answer look at
homeschooling homeschooling can prevent
bullying I can do a question mark and I
can actually answer that with five
points are you seeing how valuable this
is let's type something else in here
let's go up to let's go up to the top
and we can type in let's say vegan let's
say vegan will type in vegan Tony on our
team him and his wife have a cooking
show and they do all vegan cooking and
if they needed to come up with a
Oh idea they can do things like I let's
zoom it in a little bit my eyes can't
read that scream let's see when let's
see vo oh uh vegan when pregnant maybe
they're making a video about that exact
topic maybe Y vegan is a bad diet they
could ask answer that question is it
good is it bad or we're vegans get
protein that is like a huge question if
you are a vegan then you get asked all
the time are you seeing the power of
this answer the public comm if you can
type that in the chat below I would love
to know what you would type into that
search bar what is your niche what is
your topic that you would be searching
now again on this one here there is a
free and a paid version so you can use
the free version there's a certain
amount that you can search per day or
you can upgrade to the to the paid
version and have unlimited access to be
able to search this now what I would do
is I would take the title here and then
I would go to the youtube search bar I
would search it to see if it's actually
something that is active and then that
would help me to know if this is my dog
chewing on a toy right by the camera and
the microphone I would take this and I
would go and I would put it into the
youtube search bar and I would see is
there competition around this what does
this look like but here's a great way to
spark an idea when you are looking for
the perfect video to do next these are
powerful video ideas that you could be
using when you're making your videos
well again just to let you know that
this website was called answer the
public comm and that will help you to
know the video ideas that you can do and
Melissa have you used answer the public
calm before yes I have it is definitely
one of the tools that I've just had in
my tool belt
ever since learning it from you guys I
don't know maybe a year ago and I think
it's really effective for like you said
actually like when you are not even sure
what where to start with your question
all you have is a keyword a lot of the
other tools that we mentioned are more
effective if you
more of like a for more formed question
on your mind sorry and this is was
really great for just I'm checking on
those key words I love that well hey
we're gonna get into the Q&A section of
today's training but again just wanted
to let you know that this video is
brought to you by YouTube this is party
buddy think master class song calm Mel
can you tell them a little bit about
think master class while I move my puppy
that is decided right now yes definitely
so think master class is perfect for you
if you are just starting out on your
youtube journey or even if you're a
little bit further along and you really
want to know how you can strategize and
put some strategy behind all of the
efforts that you are doing on youtube so
if you are just feeling like I need
clarity I need a way to figure out how
to take this like pressing record and
throwing something out on the YouTube
and actually put some strategy behind it
actually put some thought and get some
clarity behind what I want to achieve on
YouTube so are you wanting to go
full-time do you want to just start
making your first hundred dollars on
YouTube this class is going to help you
work towards those goals and what you
need to figure out for those so it is a
really great opportunity for like I said
if you're if you're not even sure that
you want to become a youtuber and you
just want to see what it would be like
to take it seriously this is a great
place for you all the way through if you
are interested in if you've been doing
YouTube for a while and you just want to
learn how to grow and make some money on
it so think masterclass comm if you want
to check that out I highly encourage it
if you have not it is a limited replay
so we do take that down and you want to
check it out now the next one we do will
be have different content so now is the
time to check it out
well awesome thank you so much Mel for
helping me during that time I needed to
do this look Ben said that was a great
tip then I want to know what are you
going to use that answer the public for
Adrienne also said this is going to be
so helpful thank you you know I think
that's right sometimes you just need
just one tip to get you fired up and
excited and listen we're gonna be
jumping into the Q&A part of today's
show if you have a question you can
submit that question by putting for
question marks before or after it could
be about this topic or any topic that
you would like to ask the think team
here today
you have Melissa Caputo who is our
marketing director here at think media
she helps with all of our funnels and
with all of our social media and with
all of our emails and inbound and
outbound communication melissa is the
gal and my role here at think media is
content creator as well as chief
operations officer so its systems and
teams and video recording and all of the
things so just to let you know kind of
the plethora of the questions we can
answer for you we'd be more than happy
to jump into that so Melissa do we have
any questions submitted yet today yes we
do and if you are joining us on YouTube
then welcome to the Q&A portion of this
training you'll be able to get this full
replay on think of marketing comm if you
are watching the replay now then join us
in the comments and let us know what
questions you guys do have so we can be
answering there in the comments with you
guys all right so first question we have
Heather is um technical okay sorry
if you are using answer the public oh
and you're just starting out on your
niche and say your niche was again like
the vegan food can you put more specific
searches in there other than just vegan
and what's an example of one of those
searches yeah you can't I was just using
one keyword um you can do multiple words
in there and it'll start to to narrow it
down for you so we can bring up answer
the public again on here and we can type
in let's say chocolate chips let's type
in chocolate chips maybe you are cooking
and
and you want to make different oh we've
hit our max already for free so there we
come because we were playing with it
earlier but you can you can put that in
there see we like free things too right
Melissa like I'm not about to pay I'll
use it for free for right now but ants
to the public yeah you can be you could
put in things so I've put like
homeschooling homeschooling kids to see
what comes up and here's the thing when
you're making when you're making videos
on YouTube you want one keyword phrase
you want the topic one keyword phrase -
one video so I would not be doing like
vegan cooking that's not actually the
video I would make I would make like
like I said vegan cooking while pregnant
or like vegan diet while pregnant good
or bad and I would maybe make a case
against which one I felt was appropriate
so you want to make sure that when
you're making your videos this is to
help spark ideas this has helped to see
how your audience is wording the
question right now what is the marketing
language that they're using it's so
important to know that your audience
probably isn't speaking the exact same
language that you are you know one of
the examples that we've done here at
think media right melissa is blurry
background that's what our audience says
but it actually is really depth-of-field
but that's not what people are typing
into the search bar so you'll want to
make sure that when you are using answer
the public you get a couple ideas you
can click Save or download that is
another thing that I do so I will type
in the word I'll save and download and
then I print it out and I look at it and
I circle the ideas that I think would
actually be great videoed ideas on that
people are searching for and so the
public is what people are actually
saying so you're making videos to answer
those questions great so I am if you
guys have any questions that you want us
to answer revolving around your YouTube
strategy and marking you to youtube
videos go ahead and put them in the
comments for us and then we can get to
those throughout this video so one of
the questions we have is how to use
keywords for a vlogger this is a
question from Mara vlogs so what
keywords can you start with as a vlogger
yeah I think there's a couple things you
can do one of the one of the strategies
with vlogging is
to be a storyteller right that's like
one of the biggest pieces and so if
you're vlogging where are you you know
one of the videos that Tony on our team
did with his wife is they went to
Universal Studios and they've logged at
Universal Studios but when they were
vlogging they were actually giving
information throughout that video so it
was a vlogs style video but it was
packed with information like I don't
remember what it was but something about
like how to visit you know or how to how
to maximize Universal Studios or in some
capacity like that so you want to be
thinking about the location or the topic
or you know the what is the story that
you are presenting inside of your vlogs
Benji Travis and Judy Travis have a
vlogging channel and you know for them
they um they talk about the foods that
they're eating you know they're talking
about being parents and so depending on
what the topic of that vlog is you want
to make sure that the topic the title
the thumbnail all match so that people
understand what that is and what the
keywords do is they help Google they
help the Machine actually understand
what your video is about and so the
point of keywords in general is to give
the Machine Google and YouTube the most
information of how to categorize your
video so that they know who to show it
to based on viewers how viewers view
different types of videos any advice for
them Melissa that you would add to that
that's exactly what I would say how
there is a lot of the successful
vlogging channels that I follow are
using that exact strategy where they'll
say that there's one promise in that
title of the video they're gonna answer
this one question for you or this one
really interesting thing that happened
and then from there like they show you a
little bit more about their day but they
make sure that they get to the answer of
that question pretty early on in the
video because you want to make sure that
that person isn't you know being baited
into a video that doesn't actually
address what they're talking about but
what it does is it will maybe I'll get
the answer to my question and then I'll
still be kind of pulled in and I'll want
to stay for the rest of their vlog and
where they're kind of showing a little
bit more about their daily life so I
think that's a really great point and if
you're not a travel vlogger maybe you're
a vlogger who
is a sustainable lifestyle vlogger
that's one of the kind of channels that
I watch and what they'll do is they'll
give you like a tip at the beginning of
it that integrates within their day
they'll show you like how to do
something or here's how I styled this
particular you know item of clothing and
then they'll go on from there so that's
exactly the same kind of tip that I
would say Heather and that's what I see
being acted on in large channels every
day yeah and you just mentioned one
thing Melissa that I think is really
critical for people who want to get into
the blogging space and that is the niche
that you're in just to vlog about your
life isn't actually probably going to
get you views and I know this might
sound really harsh and please just take
it with love but people aren't actually
interested in your life they're only
actually interested in the the niche
that you're in and the style of video
that you're doing is a vlog style video
does that make sense right like it's not
like if I were to just pick up the
camera and just vlog about my day well I
mean like my mom's interested in that
but like not any other human on earth
really cares about what my day looks
like but when I pick up the camera from
the angle of a homeschool mom and I walk
through my homeschool day and it's a day
in the life of a homeschool family well
now I'm within a niche now I have people
who are searching for that now I have
interests within that Melissa said that
very well
sustainable living she's interested in
what does it look like to live a
sustainable life
there's tips and there's tools and
there's gadgets and there's things and
there's there's products and services
that those people are using that are
helpful and that's what the style of
video that they're greeting Madelyn who
is a part of the think team I guess part
of the think team because Nolan is a
part of the think team battle and is his
wife she had a lifestyle channel and in
her lifestyle channel she was just
making videos just about her life but
when she switched to doing thrifting
because she loves going to thrift stores
and buying things and altering clothes
and she started to do videos about going
and thrifty and about being married
young and and really thinking about the
topics that she was talking about that's
when she broke through to her audience
when she started doing hulls from when
she when she was going through thing
that's when she
started to break through to her audience
so I want you to think about that if you
are in the vlogging space what is the
topic what is the niche the style of
video I'm doing is a vlog style video
but what am i actual is the value of
this video
who is this serving and how am i serving
them well how am i helping them and I
hope that gives you some tips if you are
a vlogger here in our community I think
that's so good because we get asked
about vlogging quite frequently because
it's popular like of course like we want
to be able to document our lives and
share it and create beautiful things out
of our daily lives we want to capture
our kids moments we want to capture
those trips that were going on so I
think a great thing to remember as well
is that just because you're not putting
it on YouTube doesn't mean you can't do
that too and I just think like a lot of
lifestyle vloggers that we hear talk
about like but I just really want to
share my trip and I don't want to have
to give a tip or something like that but
that's okay and you know you can still
post that on YouTube but you have to
know like where your what your goal is
is your goal to grow a YouTube channel
is your a goal to go full-time on
YouTube then you're gonna want to listen
to what Heather's telling you how there
is an expert and she is giving you a
really great advice right now you're
gonna have to probably follow that
advice it's gonna be very few exceptions
if your goal is to document your life
and create beautiful pieces of art out
of your daily life then that is a
beautiful goal and yeah it might just be
your mom and your you know your spouse
watching it and that's okay that's okay
we just have to align ourselves with our
our goals and and I think that's again
just like a really something that I've
wanted to say to a lot of people and our
community as we're having that
conversation
so just remember searching giving value
serving your audience that's what's
really gonna help you grow on YouTube
okay and so I have another question we
can switch gears a little bit going a
little analytics here so we have a
question about from Edwin or sorry
actually from Adrian asking how does the
length of your video affect the YouTube
algorithm does the algorithm prefer
certain links or what is what is that
dynamic look like Heather yeah really
great question and I love the complexity
of this question because you know the
answer is the YouTube algorithm likes
both the YouTube algorithm like short
videos and long videos the YouTube
algorithm here's what I want you to
write down minutes matter most minutes
matter most so if the length of your
video and we want to get people watching
the whole time right we want to keep
people on the platform so if the length
of your video is 10 minutes but it could
have been 8 minutes because there was 2
minutes of just kind of fluff in there
and it wasn't bringing value and it
didn't really have a purpose well people
will probably start dropping off and
YouTube wants to keep people watching on
the platform so long-form videos and
short form videos are great the video
we're doing right now is a long-form
video we are gonna probably go for 30
minutes an hour this is a long-form
video and while you're watching this
right now YouTube is giving us brownie
points they're giving us gold stars
because we're keeping you on this video
we're keeping you on the platform and so
long form and short form videos another
thing I want you to write down is your
videos should be as long as they need to
be but as short as possible
Melissa and I could probably do a QA for
4 hours straight right now like we
really could go hardcore and do a
four-hour QA but is that gonna bring
value to our audience we know that our
key point like our key time when we're
doing these types of things is between
30 and an hour that's about a time where
someone's either driving they're working
out they're on a walk like that is the
time that you would be listening to this
type of a long-form piece of content now
our regular YouTube videos we like to
keep those around 10 minutes but there's
some videos we post that are 5 minutes
and you want to just remember that it
needs to be as long as it needs to be
but as short as possible you want to be
brief be bright be fun and be done that
is what our mentor chalene johnson says
and I really take that to heart when
making videos now here is a power tip
for you though when you're making video
content that is longer than say 15
minutes you're actually able to put in
additional ad placements into your video
so you can increase
your ad revenue by placing additional
ads in the video now take this lightly
because you don't want to just be
throwing a bunch of ads into your videos
we do this strategically here I think
media we teach you how to do this inside
of our think tank which is a one-day
masterclass with Sean and inside of our
mastermind we teach them some like deep
dive things into analytics but I just
want to encourage you that it's really
smart to be making videos where you can
look at your analytics and then see when
are people dropping off you know about
how long are your you know do you have a
couple videos that are 25 minutes and no
one's watching them or do you have a
couple videos that are 20 minutes and
everyone's watching them so it really
depends on your channel it depends on
the video I hope I'm not confusing you
but YouTube likes both but what YouTube
gives you brownie points for is for
keeping people on the platform so if
they watch one video and go to another
video and go to another video and
they've watched all those videos all the
way through you get more brownie points
its how the system works so that's the
algorithm in a nutshell for you about
the best ways to what length of video
should you have and we actually have a
video on YouTube right now that talks
about the length of videos and so we'll
make sure to add that into the show
notes after this broadcasts awesome I
haven't actually a question about that
we just put in the chat happy every day
happy every day could you tell me what
your niche is they're saying I'm worried
because I can't find anyone else that's
like me I assume that they're saying
that's doing my kind of content and some
worry that there might be no potential
for me to succeed or find an audience
and so I'm happy every day let me know
what is the niche that you're in and I
actually have a few thoughts on this
because I've I've struggled with this a
little bit being in the niche that I am
in I've talked to Heather and Shawn and
you know on my personal channel and just
saying like what I just don't see a lot
of search volume around the thing is
that I want to talk about and something
that again I'm gonna go back to that
idea of what is your goal because this
is really what it what it comes around
to Heather can give this an answer from
another perspective because I have an
idea of something she might say but I
want to
say this first is that I have a topic
that I am really passionate about I
really want to talk to people about
ethically made products and a lot of the
keywords and all of the questions around
that topic just aren't super popular in
search because it's something that's not
as huge on YouTube as some of these
other you know more mainstream topics
but my goal isn't necessarily to be big
on YouTube my goal isn't to be famous on
YouTube my goal is to share about that
topic because it's something that I'm
really passionate about and so yes there
are you know tactics and there are
things that we can do in order to help
support that but I you know ultimately
I'm going to be thinking like you know
maybe I'll only ever have a you know a
micro channel or smaller channel that's
under 10,000 subscribers and that's okay
because I am really passionate about
reaching those people who want to learn
about this topic because that's the
topic that I'm passionate about so
that's the first thing I wanted to say
just has like a baseline of like if it's
okay and I'm just gonna say this again
just like with the vlogging it's okay to
not get you know million subscribers
it's okay to not have a huge channel we
can still work around that and there
actually are some top there are some
tactics that you can can do to still
work in a small niche like that and I'll
let Heather speak to a little bit of
those but just being somebody who has
struggled with this a little bit myself
I wanted to put that out there as a
baseline so Heather do you want to jump
on and speak a little bit more to this
question yeah really great question um
there's a couple things I want to
I love how Melissa said you know if it
is your passion and that's what you're
passionate about a thousand true fans
that's what you need you need a thousand
true fans you actually don't need a
million you really only need a thousand
true fans and if you're in a smaller
niche there's also probably sub-niches
around that that you can impact maybe
you can pull on those sub niches meaning
like tangent niches to what you're doing
I'm be able to pull on that but I want
you to remember a thousand true fans a
thousand true fans that buy something
from you at say $25
every single month you make a full-time
living off of that a thousand true fans
that are soap impacted by what you're
doing could be the thing that helps you
write the book that becomes a New York
Times bestseller that then goes out into
the world like you don't actually have
to go crazy you don't have to be super
big to be super known I think it's
really important to remember that if the
niche that you're in isn't huge and
popular will one decide am i doing this
for a passion or profit am I like really
like Melissa said what's the goal of
what you're doing and then to just
remember that not everything is going to
be huge like my channel as a homeschool
mom is probably never going to go to a
million subscribers I mean let's be
hopeful I would love if more people were
interested in that topic but it's just I
mean it's more popular now than it was
before but it's nothing compared to tech
right it's nothing compared to - I don't
know I'm trying to think of other big
things to you know PewDiePie's meme
reviews like it's nothing compared to
that because it is a subculture within
our culture makes sense but I'm ok with
that
could I make a full-time living off of
it absolutely I could offer courses or
memberships I could write a book I could
do my YouTube channel and have it
sponsored I've already gotten free
curriculum that's helped our family be
able to teach our kids and not have to
pay for it there's so many things
there's there's homeschool families
right now that are very very small they
got free cruises and have gone to
Disneyland and have done these things
with seven children by the way because
they're reaching a sub niche and brands
want that and partnerships want that and
so when you think about the niche that
you're in 1 are you passionate about it
and then - I'd really think about lemon
you said no one's doing what I'm doing
well I want you to thinking like is that
the right needs to be in like if no
one's doing what you're doing then it's
not technically proven now it doesn't
mean you can't pioneer something new but
it's really good if there's actually
already a tribe to jump into like it's
really good to be able to jump into
something that's already like a
foundations kind of already laid so I'd
want you to say to do a couple things
one if there's nobody doing it maybe
just think about you know
do you need to go a lair out from the
lair that you're trying to get to right
maybe you just need to go one layer out
like say homeschooling was like not
popular no one was looking for it no one
had done YouTube channels on it and I
was trying to pioneer something new
maybe I would start with like motherhood
and then I could talk about
homeschooling makes sense like there's a
way that you can get to the things you
want to talk about but just think about
those two things is this something
you're super passionate about there's
actually people doing it but it is super
small or is no one doing it and you need
to stake take a step out of that that
niche and go one layer higher I think
that that'll satisfy that question I
think Melissa
yep that's the exact piece of advice I
was looking for you to give Heather
because it's again something that we've
talked about before is just that idea of
like maybe it's maybe there are ways
that you can expand a little bit and
grow a little bit even if it's not your
favorite thing ever to talk about and
the other thing is a lot of times
Melissa people will say well no one on
YouTube is doing what I'm doing yet but
are their blogs or their books are their
forums is there already a tribe around
the thing we I don't know what the thing
is I don't know what their niche is but
I would just be thinking about that like
a lot of times when I'm coaching older
women who are trying to reach older
women on YouTube though say things like
no one's watching my videos well 24
women watch their videos and I'm like
that's 24 women that are older like say
in their 50s or 60s that understand how
to use YouTube like they're getting
there they're gonna be there so but
there's blogs and there's books and
there's there's whole communities
already there they just might not be in
droves like people are with tech on
YouTube right so just be thinking also
shifting your mindset that you know
think about 24 views think about a
hundred views I think sometimes Melissa
we we compare ourselves to big channels
and you know 124 people is the size of a
classroom that's you giving a class to
24 people who are actually interested in
what you're talking about think about a
hundred a hundred people that's two
classrooms think about a thousand views
that's filling an auditorium of people
and you standing
with a microphone talking about the
things you want to talk about I think
sometimes we get tripped up on the
numbers because we want the big numbers
but when we think about who we're
actually impacting with the message it's
really important to remember that every
one of those views was a person watching
your video that you put out some I
really want to reframe sometimes how we
think about the things that we're
passionate about in the videos that
we're creating absolutely and Heather
you know you're talking about are there
people off of YouTube who are interested
in this topic and I think that's a good
segue into a couple of the other
questions that we got because we're
getting questions from Benjamin and
Edwin about how can I use these YouTube
strategies how can I bring people onto
YouTube using Instagram or Facebook and
so Benjamin saying you know how can I
turn my Instagram followers into YouTube
subscribers and so let's get into some
tactics here let's let's get into some
of the the really practical things that
we can do in order to bring our audience
onto YouTube I think one of the main
things that we always preach about you
know when you want to build a platform
aside from YouTube so if you're saying I
mean if I'm a youtuber but I'm also
gonna like use an Instagram in order to
grow my YouTube channel I want to just
pause you for a second and reframe that
again because if you are only using your
Instagram account to tell people to go
watch your YouTube videos you're
probably not gonna grow you're probably
not gonna grow your Instagram profile
and and again this is like what heather
says like we don't like sorry what we
will give you is some like honest truth
that is just not really an effective way
to grow on Instagram now if you have an
Instagram platform already and you have
people who are following you and engage
and you just start it up on YouTube
there are ways that you can let those
people know that you have a YouTube
channel but if you want to grow on any
other platform other than YouTube you're
going to need to cater to that audience
that is on that platform and you're
going to need to give them unique
content you're going to need to engage
with them you're gonna need to ask them
questions and listen to them and really
be engaged on Facebook or on Instagram
you're not going to just drop a link to
your YouTube channel and then
and then come back the next time you
have YouTube channels say hey go watch
my YouTube video because if you think
about that that is serving you that is
not serving your Facebook audience it's
not serving your Instagram audience that
is serving you you are trying to just
get views to your video and you're not
really caring for that relationship and
so the first thing I want to say is
Benjamin if you already have an
Instagram profile and you just want to
know about moving people off we're going
to get to that in a second but if you've
just started on YouTube and then you're
also just trying to start up an
Instagram account maybe don't maybe you
don't right now and it's just something
to think about we talked about chasing
two rabbits at a time what are you
chasing if you chase two rabbits you're
gonna catch none but if you can just
focus and dial in on your YouTube
channel and really focus on coming up
with questions that are being searched
in that YouTube search bar serving
people answering questions grow their
first and then you know after you feel
like you have a sustainable platform for
that then you can move on to Instagram
and then we'll start you know creating
content for Instagram and building that
and using some of these topics so that's
the first thing that we always just want
to caution you in is that you are really
focusing on your most important thing
but that's like my little disclaimer but
I also want to get into some some actual
tangible tactics here and one thing with
Instagram if you do have a following on
there and say you are let's go back to
Heather's homeschooling example Heather
has a YouTube channel for homeschooling
and then she has her Instagram where she
also talks about homeschooling so she
has an audience on there and what she
can do is even though she might not
Heather's channel she can put swipe up
links but if you can't put swipe up
links and you can't link to a video in a
YouTube caption how can you get people
to move from Instagram to YouTube so we
use a lot of there's ways that in your
link in your bio this is just a really
practical tip you have a you have the
opportunity to put a link in your bio
and for small Instagram profiles you
might be the only way that you can put a
link in your profile and so use that as
effectively as possible so Toni what I
believe Tony is doing here is
he has put his latest video in his
YouTube by or sorry in his Instagram bio
and so when he's talking about a new
channel he can go here he makes a new
post he's like hey I have a new video on
this and then he can and it says Lincoln
bio and so he can just change that out
every week if he has a weekly video he
can change that to his most recent video
another way you can do this is you can
use different apps like tap bio or link
tree are ways that you can actually link
multiple things in your bio so those are
effective tools to be able to say like
hey check the link in my bio and you can
actually put your your most recent if
you have a website you can put that on
there - you can put your 3 most recent
videos you can put your channel on there
and so that's a really a practical way
to use that but the advanced tactic I
don't want to give you right now is to
actually think about the post that
you're doing that is seeding to your
your YouTube channel video what I mean
is if you just write a and if you just
put an Instagram post and you're like
hey I have a new video go watch it you
know maybe you have some loyal fans that
want to go watch your video but if you
actually maybe take a photo or you know
something interesting out of your
YouTube video maybe you're taking a
micro piece of it or you take a photo
and you give some value up front and you
say you know today here's my tip for two
books that are gonna be really great for
YouTube or for homeschooling and you
write out your caption and you give some
really great value to your audience and
then you say and actually if you want to
know three more of my recommendations
check out my latest youtube video linked
in bio and so what that does is you've
already given them something really
valuable and they say oh yes that was a
really great tip thank you I actually do
want more tips like that and then that
gives just more incentive for them to
actually go and watch your video and so
that's like my advanced tactic for you
beyond just saying like new video posted
link and bio I hope that hope that helps
and maybe Heather wants to jump on and
clarify this I gave like five tips all
in one right here just got excited so
powerful and if you're getting value
out of this video make sure you hit that
like button and let us know in the
comments below
are you using Instagram right now right
now like are you using Instagram to try
and bring people over and did that tip
just help you was that an unlock and aha
I loved how you said that Melissa that
like you have to grow one channel like
grow YouTube for YouTube and grow
Instagram for Instagram but deliver
value deliver value and one additional
power tip I want to tell you is that go
join the conversation like make sure
your stuff is set up right on Instagram
and then go join the conversations that
are happening so if I wanted to grow my
Instagram and then grow my youtube
channel I would go to other
homeschoolers and I would start
interacting with people on their on
their instagrams like I would go to
where the conversation is if I want to
grow my youtube channel I would go to
the other channels that are like my
channel and I would answer the questions
that people are asking or I would engage
with them I'm not spamming I'm not
sub4sub I'm not like dropping my links
to things but if I have an answer to a
question I want to do that and then
guess what happens you know you're like
me you click on that bye you're like
who's this person you click on the bio
and you're like oh that's cool they do
this too and you kind of scroll through
their feet a little bit and like oh well
they do home swing
oh cool they read that one post that
said they have a video well I'm gonna
head over to YouTube I'm gonna check it
out right like you're just like me
you you know how people are so that's
how you inadvertently can grow your
Instagram and your YouTube channel at
the same time is by bringing value
you'll hear us say that over and over
again here I think you need to bring
value to your audience it's not about
you it's about them okay so when you're
going through your your strategies take
what ballista just set make sure you're
set up right and then execute on those
tactics well I'm fired up Melissa let's
give maybe one or two more questions in
here today we've got a great audience
that's happening tat bio is inside of
the chat and we'll make sure that that
is also linked down below in the
description of this video so if you want
to go over to tap bio and check it out
for yourself we've been using it here at
think media and I really like it Melissa
yeah it's it's definitely a great tool
and I guess I don't focus so much on the
tools when you're first starting focus
on
livering that value like Heather said
and so when so while we're talking about
these like really practical tips for
social media strategy Heather Edwin is
asking how can I use our church's
Facebook page to promote our YouTube
channel our videos and our subscribers
this is a really really similar question
but how does this apply to your Facebook
page yeah I mean really what's great
about Facebook is the same things about
Instagram so if you're like how am i
using my Facebook page to promote my
youtube channel I want you to think
differently I want you to think how can
I grow my Facebook page for my Facebook
page and then also offer the value
they'll let them know that there's
additional things over on YouTube so
here's what you can do
maybe you post your video over on
YouTube and then you come on Facebook at
your church does you come on Facebook
the pastor maybe another person and they
do a live Q&A around that topic and
during that live Q&A they refer back to
the video and hey if you want more about
this topic or you know what if you if
you're interested in going deeper on
Ecclesiastes make sure you check out the
new video that we just posted or make
sure you check out last weekend's sermon
where I talked about that the death of
that right like there's ways that you
can be seating it throughout but you're
offering value on that platform and
here's the thing you might have to
educate your audience on how to even use
YouTube I know it sounds crazy because
you're here you're probably watching
this on youtube you consume YouTube
you're like duh YouTube but people are
not understanding how to use the
platform yet I literally just showed my
mom that she has two different pages she
has a home page and she has the
subscriber feed she did not even know
that that was a thing so there's so many
people that are still learning how to
use these tools and so educating them
walking them through them using a
software like we're using right now
stream yard or you can bring it up and
you can actually show the visuals like
I'll have Tony do on the backend he'll
bring up the visuals for you and show
you think media and I like I did their
presentation before this this little
segment here you can actually bring up
different things and you can show people
how they can start to see the different
lessons
that you've taught on YouTube but how do
you grow your Facebook page - how do you
move people from Facebook to YouTube I
want you to grow your Facebook page for
Facebook and growing your YouTube page
for YouTube bring value on the platform
and then offer them the idea that they
can go over to the other platform I hope
that helps you I think this is something
that you're just could do way more of
and if you pioneer this I'll bet you'll
be a really good case study one day for
us here I think media to share with the
rest of the world I love this question
from Alba saying what what what what do
you recommend if for not creating
selfish content like what does it even
mean to not create selfish content
Heather hmm I think that's a really
great question and to not create selfish
content is to think about the viewer the
entire time when we're creating videos
here I think media we are thinking about
you when we're creating videos I think
marketing we're thinking about you it's
so important to us to know the language
that you're saying we want to solve the
problem how do we make the content not
selfish we solve the problem now don't
get me wrong we are making videos on
YouTube and making money off of those
videos on YouTube so obviously there is
some selfishness to it like I'm not just
putting it out there into the world just
to be just completely uh you know just
transparent we're putting the video out
on YouTube because we make money off of
youtube and those videos and it goes
into the business and there's a whole
thing built up behind it it's a channel
to build influence but the videos
themselves the content that we're doing
the actual topics that we're picking
they're all for you
we are deeply passionate about your
success like deeply passionate about it
and so for you to make unselfish content
is to just always be thinking about your
viewer am I saying it right for them
would they understand this are they
already at the point where this topic
would make sense are they even searching
this what problem does my - my target
audience have and how can I help them
what tools have I used that that have
changed my life and that I want to share
those with others what software have I
used what habits have I done
right that is unselfish
because you're sharing and you're
delivering something of value to your
audience Melissa you have anything else
to add to that one because I know this
is a big thing on social media we get a
lot of selfie culture and how can we
make sure that we're not making selfish
content on platforms yeah so I think the
same exact strategy that Heather just
talked about applies across platforms
that's the same on YouTube it's the same
on Facebook it's the same on Instagram
when we are making an Instagram post yes
you want it to be relational yes it's a
little bit more relational than maybe
YouTube is and you want to add some
things about yourself and you want to
talk about things that are personal but
especially if you're just starting out
an Instagram account or a Facebook
account you want to be giving actual
tips and this is another question that
somebody said in the chat was you know
how do I deliver a value like what does
that even mean to deliver value on my
Instagram account and so it what it
means is to answer questions like
Heather was saying it's to think about
who do I want to attract and what do
they need how can I help that person and
so on Instagram the same exact thing
applies you can say I'm gonna post this
image and you know whether that is an
image of yourself or whether it's a you
know a short video it's a IG TV clip
like this and then you give actual
tangible value and what I mean by value
is you answer a question you give them a
tip you give them a tool you give them
something that will help them and so I
want you to focus on maybe those two
categories think about can I give what
tip can I give what tool can I suggest
and what you know what question can I
answer those are three different things
that you can ask yourself to start
sparking you know maybe your next
Instagram post what can I do and you
know longer form Instagram posts are
great give some details gives them you
know it's like a mini little blog post
where you can actually talk a little bit
more about what that topic is and and
ship it send it that's your Instagram
post for the day you don't even have to
tell them to go to YouTube just give
them something that's really helpful for
them
and then the next day do the same thing
the next day maybe you have a clip a
micro post like we were just showing you
maybe you have a micro post like that
that gives value in the form of a video
and you answer a question and then you
say hey if you want to watch the rest of
the video where this tip came from then
you can go to youtube but you're still
giving them something that they can walk
away with and we talked a lot about
results you know can you help somebody
make a change in in their life today if
we're helping you with saying like
here's how to get better audio because
with you know this quick hack then
you're able to walk away and you could
sit down and actually get better audio
after reading that Instagram post how
cool is that like I could actually
change somebody's day I could change the
way that they do something with one
Instagram post and that I think is what
delivering value looks like and that's
what delivering content that cares about
your viewer looks like you are helping
them how can you help somebody and a you
know it applies to YouTube it applies to
Instagram it applies to Facebook and
applies across platforms and I think
that's that's like our tip of the the
Q&A Heather because that really is what
so much of this comes out of and that's
why you go to answer the public bring it
back around to our tip that's why you go
to answer the public because you want to
know how can I help that person who's
interested in vegan cooking I want to
know how I can help them I don't want to
just make something that like you know
because I think it'll be fun or I'll be
good obviously that's great and
obviously we want you to enjoy what
you're doing but how can you really help
somebody sorry yeah miss excited well it
was such a great tip and I loved it and
what Matthew said he said answer
questions is a great tip I should do
that more often absolutely you know one
of the things we teach here at think is
to answer specific questions a lot of
times people make content and it's got
all this stuff in it and you're like you
walk away and you go is that really
valuable did I just waste 15 minutes of
my life but when it's so rich and it's
answering a specific question
they walk away with value they walk away
with something changed I love what Ben
said he said give them something they
can walk away with that is exactly the
purpose of all content we want you to be
making content all over the Internet
that is helping people walk away with
something and Melissa I think that's a
great place to leave this video today
and just to let you know again if you've
not checked out our free masterclass I
highly recommend that you go over to our
one our free youtube masterclass this
Q&A session was brought to you by the
think masterclass so if you want to grow
on YouTube and you like tips like this
and videos like this you can check out
this one-hour free class that the CEO of
think media does Sean kennel and he
teaches you the step-by-step strategies
for winning on YouTube this year and if
you like videos like this make sure to
hit that like button make sure to hit
the subscribe button and if you want to
check out another video like this here
on the think media show on the think
media channel make sure to check the
video that's popping up on the screen
right now and we will catch you in the
next video thanks so much for watching
we'll see you next time bye